الارتقاء إلى مستوى التحدي ،
يتضمن قانون الاستثمار والوظائف في البنية التحتية من
بين أحكام أخرى ،
أكبر استثمار اتحادي في النقل العام
في التاريخ ، أكبر استثمار في
مياه الشرب النظيفة
والبنية التحتية لمياه الصرف الصحي في
التاريخ ، أكبر استثمار في نقل الطاقة النظيفة
في التاريخ ، الأكبر  الاستثمار في
مرونة المناخ في التاريخ
وأكبر استثمار في
كهربة النقل
في التاريخ هو مشروع القانون هذا مثاليًا ، ولا
يوجد أي تشريع وسط على الإطلاق ، ولكنه
سيحدث فرقًا كبيرًا في
تحديث البنية التحتية لبلدنا
أكثر من أننا سنثبت أن
كل من الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
يمكن أن يأتوا  معًا والقيام بأشياء كبيرة
تدفع بلدنا إلى الأمام ،
هذا ليس بالضبط مشروع القانون الذي كنت
سأكتبه بمفردي
في مكتبي ، وقد يقول 99 من
زملائي نفس الشيء تمامًا ، هذا منتج
مخترق صنعه زملاء لديهم
اختلافات مبدئية كبيرة  في مجلس الشيوخ مع
أضيق
الانقسام المحتمل ، لكن في رأيي ، فإن
ما أسماه رجل الدولة الأوائل
التحسين الداخلي هو مسؤولية حكومية أساسية
، يحتاج الأمريكيون إلى
طرق
وجسور وموانئ ومطارات
لبناء أعمالهم وبناء عائلاتهم وبناء
حياتهم.
تشمل الرؤى
البنية التحتية المادية التي تعمل مع جميع
مواطنينا ،
يمكننا إنجاز ذلك بالطريقة السهلة أو
بالطريقة الصعبة
في كلتا الحالتين ، سيبقى مجلس الشيوخ
في الجلسة حتى ننتهي من عملنا ،
الأمر متروك لزملائي الجمهوريين كم من
الوقت يستغرقه
الأجانب
مشروع قانون من شأنه أن ينهي سنوات من
الجمود في واشنطن
ويخلق الملايين من الوظائف ذات الأجور الجيدة ، فإن
تسعين بالمائة من الوظائف التي تم إنشاؤها بموجب
هذا التشريع
لن يتطلب شهادة جامعية
بنسبة 90 بالمائة ،
إنه مخطط من ذوي الياقات الزرقاء لإعادة بناء
أمريكا
الأجنبية.